[Applause]
one question an amazing lineup of ceos
founders and experts this is marketing
for the now
[Music]
thank you so much that made me feel
thank you
[Music]
hey gary
i don't know why that still makes me
laugh
the the beatboxing yeah yeah yeah it's
awesome
i love you economy on vcon it's coming
is it coming
we're a month a little short of a month
away um
can the big market festival i know you
and i are working on that we're in the
depths of 2022
obviously vayner media has been getting
a ton of industry accolades so our new
business team is crazy busy and i know
you've been busy
interacting with all
of the marketers as well and it's just
nice to be back on marketing for the now
yeah i know it's great and we're going
to talk we're going to talk about some
of those hot takes we're kind of yeah
what are we we're we're into q1 we're
heading into q2 big time so let's uh we
got a great lineup we're going to have
kick things off with sophie bambuck
she's the cmo of everlane and she's the
first ever cmo at everlane but she comes
from a 13-year career at nike and she
held roles as cmo of converse and headed
up brands for nike sportswear as well so
welcome sophie
thanks thanks for having me hi guys
hi soap how are you
i'm good i'm good
it's great how are you doing
yeah same here
let's get right into it you know we only
have 10 minutes these things go fast so
what are your hot takes for 2022 in the
first kind of
three three and a half months
give me something that you had a
hypothesis going into 2022 on that's
working and give me something that in
the last
14 15 weeks
is starting to really bounce around in
that brilliant marketing head of yours
of like oh man we need to do more of
this or we're not taking this serious or
what's that shiny thing over there is
that
is that just sizzle or is there steak
under that sizzle yeah
uh i don't know about brilliance uh i'll
just share what i have to show what's in
my head um i think the the big thing and
obviously i work at everlane um and it's
not because it's earth months or
anything but i think the topic of
sustainability is a big one
and i think it's becoming it's ramping
up
um if you think about how
it took like a major event for kind of
like dei efforts to be on everybody's
minds and i don't mean just corporate
like from a brand a marketing standpoint
it became like what is it that we're
saying what are we doing i think
sustainability is seeing this
um happening i think it's on everybody's
mind
the problem i think in my opinion is
that nobody's figured out how to make
sustainability sexy nobody's figured out
how to make it something that is um
honestly interesting and so it's it's
one of those where you're seeing it more
and more i mean uh and obviously i
follow sustainability closely but
whether it's media or just pushing you
know through pr and you know media
articles
brand every collection you know from an
apparel standpoint everybody's coming
out with their sustainability take you
know
i mean you know i'm sorry to jump in but
yeah i will tell you because i do this
for a living when you look at the
interests of 18 and under
this is now
table stakes this is not sizzle like i i
have a 12 year old daughter
she doesn't even think in the concept of
a product
it's a cost of entry it's almost as if
like
there's no other perspective and
you obviously your company was such a
pioneer but the companies that are doing
you know this is business life right
where you're making a lot of money
you're not sustainable if they don't
figure that [ __ ] out within this decade
i i think the market is going to be very
cruel to them you know everyone's
everyone's
lightweight altruistic in business world
about issues that matter the second the
consumer turns on you you very much you
know you could be the least
earth-loving person on earth the second
the consumers only buy if it is
a hundred that and that and that's what
i keep telling my friends i'm like we're
now in yellow this isn't red we're in
yellow and it's about you're green and
they're gonna all leave you behind
that's just business talk not even hey
let's [ __ ] live on this earth
totally we don't have and arguably i
don't think we have 10 years to figure
it out i actually think we've had the
past 10 years to figure it out we
haven't figured it out now we got to
hurry up and actually get together and i
think though one of the issue also why
it's not getting figured out faster is
that everybody's using sustainability as
a competitive advantage
right like you're actually looking at
here's what i'm doing here's my shiny
object here's why you should come to me
where really to actually figure it out
you it actually requires collaboration
because nothing happens in isolation
when you have a brand new
concept or idea and so but you're
totally right i mean i think i just saw
a report recently that was just saying
that um brand name you know there's
still a lot of retailers who assume that
brand name um uh have more value in the
consumer eyes nowadays where actually
we're seeing
that consumers are starting to value
product sustainability over brand name
like there's a transition starting to
happen but you're definitely to your
point like you're definitely seeing it
much
more in that younger audience a lot of
everlane's consumer is still you know
millennials and
i mean they've been on it for a while
but it was like a nice to have versus a
must-have that younger audience it's a
must-have so you have to figure it out
um and maybe in a way it's a hot take
but a hot topic for 2022 but also like
uh and ask uh we all need to get on it
together because otherwise we're never
gonna figure it out like it's it's hard
to figure out on your own let's let's
talk about the marketing of it you know
i was just in the discord while you were
talking talking to my friend homie in
the defense discord i'm looking at
what's going on on tick-tock you know
when you're running a business where you
know the date is so clear
under 25 under 30 i've got an audience
that's fully bought into what i'm saying
for the last seven minutes over 35
there's a percentage as you get older
and so we're going through this thing
not that the ogs don't remember earth
day they went crazy on earth day back in
the day but you know it is it is that
what do you think about from a marketing
standpoint getting that message out for
some of the new stuff how do you think
about discord how do you think about
tick tock where are you and the brand on
that journey
yeah we're
we're scratching the surface i think um
but we're getting in it i think tick
tock has the opportunity tik tok is a
great place to educate people tick tock
is where you get all your tips tick-tock
is where you're getting like i mean i
just learned how to like make a dish on
tik-tok like recently it's just like
it's one of those where
and i'm obviously older so i used to
maybe tech talk a little bit differently
but it's a place where you can actually
educate go and educate the dilemma right
now i think i really think cancer
culture is hurting everybody
this idea you know i think cancer
culture is making everybody avoid risk
because there's an expect expectation
that we're at
perfection and that you know progress
doesn't need to and experimentation
the over aggressive canceling even on
subtle things is creating an
overreaction to just vanilla
it's the danger we're in right now it's
in order to succeed you have to try and
you have to be okay failing
and right now failing is no longer
accepted um in some parts and and i
think that's the danger of cancelled
culture it's like if you're not perfect
you could give your company
yeah where companies have a real tough
time so for example as a personal brand
and i know that i have a big audience as
a human being
i'm i take a ton of risks
but the reason i do
is because i know my intent
right i know my intent which means god
forbid if i misstep which for somebody
who speaks so much i've done pretty well
because of my intent
yeah but if i do i'm incredibly capable
of saying i'm sorry as a human being
and i've done that last 15 years
publicly when i've had to
i think for brands
brands
also often do have good intent a lot of
times not but a lot of times more so
than you know i'm under a hood now for
the last 13 years
it's not like they're trying to do the
worst [ __ ] of all time
the problem is
that's right the problem is
they suck and i'm sorry
yeah
i think knock it off
like and transparency like transparency
is so important it's like here's why we
did this um and here's why we did this
and here's why we're not there yet or
here's why we failed um like actually
like last last year we had this whole
thing around like the last percent we're
almost there on no longer using virgin
plastic but we're not all the way there
because we haven't figured everything
out and you have to be honest you have
to be transparent you have to be
authentic um and your mission has got to
be
like it can't just be a display
for the consumer it's got to be
something you live and breathe
as a company and actually kind of like
do everything uh for
and
i don't do that
yeah a lot of companies are confused as
if they have to be perfect i keep
telling people if you look carefully if
it's okay to be like yo we sell this
[ __ ]
like it's actually okay it's when you
try to make raton you're not selling
this [ __ ] and you're like yo
but like that's where people get crazy
yeah totally
i mean it's also it's also when people
start
uh virtue signaling others when they're
vulnerable and sustainability i have so
many friends who are passionate about it
which makes me passionate about it i'm
passionate about it but what i don't do
is [ __ ] on everybody for every move
because when i have friends who shut on
everybody for it i'm like well what
about with the plane you like literally
ugly friends who try to [ __ ] on people
for sustainability while flying private
planes all around the country when they
don't always happen
you know and so i think hypocrisy is a
devastating blow
for sure and
again i think everybody that is touching
aspirations
people who are in the sustainability
space really are there for the right
reasons and it's the right intention i
think it's but he needs to get in it
everybody needs to have
um a point of view at least and be able
to respond to it so that they don't get
left behind like every burn now has to
have some sort of responsibility to it
and it's really about figuring out how
to make it interesting and simple for
the consumer to understand it because
i mean it's major science and it's
complex so we have to boil it down to
the essential and to
we need to figure out how to make it
sexy
agreed so thanks for being on the show
continued success
thank you so much
cheers
thank you sophie
so gary next up we have gretchen rubin
she is one of my favorites she is my
podcast girl crush she's an expert on
habits happiness and human nature she's
a three times new york times
best-selling author a blogger a speaker
and she just received nominations for
two webby awards welcome gretchen
hello i'm so happy to be talking to you
today
hey gretchen
hey
um
let's go right into it
short 10 minutes what are your hottest
takes with consumer behavior in 2022
what are you seeing
one of the things i'm saying is i think
people are very focused on our five
senses i think we've been you know
distanced from each other we've been
behind screens we haven't been showing
up and people i see are just hungry they
want to touch they want to taste they
want to smell they want to like feel
those air currents between them and
other people they want to show up they
want to be in person and i think
anything that offers kind of this
tactile physical concrete experience
gets people very excited whether it's
like like i had a taste party for a
bunch of friends and i just had a bunch
of like weird tastes for us all to
experiment with or like here are the
three kinds of apples like you know
rate them um a planetarium um a museum
exhibit that is this like that
experiments with sound um you know in
immersive like how many things now right
that's like the word everybody's using
is immersive but that's because it's
irresistible we're so hungry to show up
that i think that that is driving a lot
of what what people are looking for
let's keep building up i'm going to go
back to that what else what else is uh
or or double clicking into details on
that um
what what else there's so many
entrepreneurs watching right now they're
trying to figure out who's the
opportunity there's a lot of parents on
here what's the opportunity
for happiness what do you what what
other things are you saying knowing that
this is what you spend your time and
energy well another thing that i'm
seeing that's sort of like a less joyful
and happy but also very important to our
happiness and health and productivity
and creativity
is habit formation you know everybody is
because of this magic a massive
disruption that we've all experienced
and we're sort of coming out of that
disruption but things are not going back
to the way they were a lot of people are
having very different
um
work looks very different how they show
up when they show up and i think just
traditionally a lot of us ever since you
know we went to kindergarten we kind of
a five day two day way of setting up our
lives we did certain things during the
week we did certain things during the
weekend this is how we exercise this is
what time we went to bed this is how we
ate these are the snacks that we had
this is just the rhythm of our family
life our friend life our work life
and you know now this is all just
getting turned upside down for many
people so like yeah maybe your kid goes
you know to fourth grade five days a
week
but you must be not going to be off
oh i'm certain interrupt correction uh
now on that
i have a really interesting back to
behavior and all that
do you feel
because it's a profound point what you
just made
do you feel
that the way we are trained up in school
for behavior
should now start to be talked about a
little bit more because it makes people
incredibly non-adaptable
in a world where the speed in which the
world is moving because of the internet
and the blockchain
is so profoundly different
than the 40s 50s 60s 70s 80s
do you think that there needs to be a
bigger conversation of how
many people go through the structured
school system to the detriment of their
adulthood
well i would actually zoom it back even
more and i don't even think it's about
the school system i think it's much more
individual and one of the things i spend
a lot of time is like thinking about how
different people respond differently
some people really flourish
in structure and they need outer
accountability and that's how they
thrive and that's what they need and
that's fine other people resist
accountability they don't want someone
looking over their shoulder they don't
want someone micromanaging them they
want they do better when they have a lot
of freedom when they're choosing what
they want to do gary i think i have an
instinct about which category you're
fitting into um
it's funny though when you were
delivering the sentence and to your
point
it i actually think the first version is
fake accountability
right like i actually obsess over
accountability so much
like i adore accountability
and but when it's when it's a
s
where you're accountable to a structure
for the sake of the structure it's like
having meetings for the sake of meetings
if the kpi's the meeting not the actual
thing the whole thing's [ __ ]
okay well i just have to say if people
want to take a quiz and find out where
they fit into it to a framework that
does this they can go to my website and
look for gretchen rubin for tennessee's
quiz because i have so many thoughts
about this
but i think like
i would talk about outer accountability
like some people need adder
accountability they need a work deadline
they need somebody to be answerable too
if they're going to work out they need
to work out with a friend or a trainer
or whatever or they need a deliverable
or they need a customer or a client and
some people don't need that and i don't
think that it's better or worse to need
it or not need it it's more a question
of like well what do you need what do
you need and how do you thrive and the
fact is because of the way it was set up
a lot of us just like if we needed that
we could just plug into a typical office
environment and it gave us whether we
wanted that or not we got it for some
people that was great for some people
that was terrible and now those people
are thriving because they're out they
have this freedom and flexibility
they've always sought and maybe couldn't
get but then there are some people who
are like wow i miss what i had i need to
replace what i had and if i don't
understand what i need
i might not set myself up for success or
if i'm managing a team i might not
understand different team members need
different things we got to rethink this
we got to recreate it what does that
look like i couldn't agree more i love
that point i you know
it would be so much more exciting if we
stood up self-awareness
and
built that up i mean to me it's been the
foundation of my
happiness
[ __ ] success away the world to me
success is a mental game not the
tangible items you can buy with [ __ ]
money and i think
to to your point the question becomes
what do we do with the half of the 50 of
people 30 percent of people
that
are
being pushed through a system
and a modern parenting infrastructure
that tells them they're not doing well
where's the options for you know
being an 18 or 22 year old to finally
find that freedom after a machine or a
culture has told you you're not going to
be great is great for the ability to
deal with negative feedback but for a
lot of people that don't have a
parenting infrastructure that builds up
their self-esteem to fight the world
they believe the world
i i just think you're so right that what
we need is insight into how people are
different from each other and instead of
saying like okay there's this
procrustean bed everybody's gotta jam
their way in it's the best way it's the
right way it's the only way it's the way
we've done it is to say hey different
people need different things how do we
get people what they need and maybe
that's going to take some
experimentation because you you you want
to you try this you try that maybe
something works maybe something sounds
great doesn't work for you but instead
of having this assumption that there's
one right way that if we could just find
it or force everybody to do it because
what a lot of people do is they say well
this works for me so that's going to
work for you no why no
you're a morning person i'm a night
person i love simplicity love abundance
you like to sprint i'm a marathoner
right there's no
and giving people permission to evolve i
mean it's you know who i'm at 16 and 32
and 44 are three different versions of
myself and giving us the opportunity to
breathe a little bit
and feel comfortable within our own skin
as we progress is profound i i want to
go back to
an incredible insight you started this
with i love this sensory thing i think
there's you know back to making this
maybe a little bit about business and
less about societal norms um
i think for the people that heard that
and can dig into you a little bit more
on your site and your socials here for
people that i want to follow i think
you're very much on to something on the
sensory part people definitely are
yearning i mean look there's a lot of
cobia going on right now and the
collective society's like we're we're
done like we're tired we're gonna like
like we're struggling which is a you
know we're struggling to accept it and
kind of just trying to push through it
which also equals to me
a very real validation of your
hypothesis that you started here with or
your observations that you're seeing i
think sensory is a big opportunity for
2022 and 23.
well and look at your conference like
it's it's people are flooding into it
people want to be in person they want to
show up they want to be with other
people um i think that that desire to
show up and to travel to experience is
going to be
kind of irresistible as you say sort of
like people are like i got i i i want it
yeah gretchen continued success great to
see you bye-bye
thanks gretchen
gary next we we bring up rachel
tipograph founder and ceo of mikmaq a
global ecommerce enablement and
analytics platform for brands
and we've known uh rachel for a while
but before
she founded mcmack rachel was at gaap as
the company's youngest ever global
director of digital and social media and
after she left gaap she traveled the
world for a hundred days before she came
gave birth to this new company welcome
rachel
hi
hi rach
how's it going
things are well um as many of my most
intense hardcore fans know i adore this
woman she is someone i give a lot of
public roses to because i love sitting
on her board interacting with her and i
cheer for her
and
i am always thirsty for more
opportunities to hang out with reach how
are you
i'm great i'm in the office
i see that 2019 here
uh well i'm so appreciative for
thank you um let's go into it what are
you seeing i mean i think you're one of
the stronger
observers that's why i'm a fan um
and uh
and i would love to hear your first 15
16 weeks into the years insight around
e-commerce big brands in e-commerce
influencers or anything else you've
decided to uh get uh intrigued by
yeah um so for context you know my
business we work with cpg brands
anywhere ranging from 50 billion in
revenue to 50 million
and so i thought gary you and i could
talk about retail media
so
you know when i started mcmac
going on seven years ago
retail media represented anywhere
between five and twenty percent of
brands budgets
today
any customer i talk to it's anywhere
between 50 and 75
and the reason why is that in many ways
it's guaranteed roi
you give amazon a dollar
they know exactly who to go and target
now the challenge with retail media
historically is that there hasn't been
enough supply right there's only so many
people that you can reach within
amazon.com target.comwalmart.com
and so what's happened
over the last 18 months is the retail
media groups have recognized this and
they're starting to try to figure out
how do i create more supply so you see
like walmart teaming up with the trade
desk
what's also happening right now in the
ecosystem that's causing retail media to
rise
is the changes that have happened
between what i like to call apple google
and facebook
industry headlines talk about a movement
towards consumer data privacy
i don't really think it's about that
i think that apple woke up one day
realized that they weren't monetizing
traffic within their phone that their
biggest competitors were monetizing that
and so apple said how do i make google
and facebook's life a lot more difficult
and fundamentally changed the way
that all of us have to go to market
which is it is so difficult now
to essentially execute the playbook that
you know gary you and i grew up with
which was the ability to remarket to
someone on the internet because it takes
multiple touch points to close the sale
that's right and
remarketing through cooking people's
browsers or phones or things that nature
and the ads showing up a third a fourth
or fifth time you were in a shopping
cart you let it sit you go somewhere
else to espn all of a sudden there it is
again you're like oh right [ __ ] boom and
that the data showed that that was an
incredibly effective way to get it
closed and then you just run the math on
how much all those ads cost you versus
the profit you made against the thing
and away we go
exactly sales now you know
sales right
which kind of actually reached in a lot
of ways killed marketing creativity in a
lot of ways because everyone became so
cac and ltv'ed out
and it's gonna be really interesting you
know i think about um
donuts
i love them
don't be dry
and i and still delicious and i think of
that as sales it's still a donut it's
good
but you give me a moist
soft doughnut that like melts in your
that's brand that's marketing and that
tastes even more delicious
you're absolutely right but because
people have become so reliant
on essentially a dollar in equals a
dollar fifty out of return they're now
leaving environments like facebook and
they're moving into retail media but
there's a challenge right now this is
this is sort of what i'm feeling in the
ecosystem over the last 16 weeks
which is that retail media is where
social media was in 2009.
so it is completely siloed
there is no standardization
very few self-serve tools and it is
really painful
so if you talk to cpg brand
manufacturers
they don't love talking about retail
media first reason why is that more and
more power is shifting to the retailers
so global supply chain crisis rising
prices and fuel like
it kind of sucks right now to sell
consumer products it's more expensive
than ever before the retailers recognize
this they need to be able to offset
their margins best way to do that is
with advertising because guess what we
learned advertising is a great business
and so they're being squeezed for
dollars but then it is so painful to
execute
there's gaps in reporting and there's no
standardization and so one of the things
that i feel really strongly about and
i'm talking with all the advocacy groups
in our industry
a a iab
like
there needs to be a new dialogue around
creating standardization in retail media
so
everyone can scale together
now playing this out for you what i
think is about to happen
is
retail media it will scale it'll reach
that 100 billion dollars that bcg talks
about and then it'll become inefficient
and then people are going to start to
swing back towards brand so they're
going to go back to facebook they're
going to go to snap
but then the attribution isn't going to
be there
and that's right
100
and
what i'm most passionate about is i love
marketing and sales and back to my donut
analogy
marketing has left the room
because the only marketing is television
commercials and that's the worst garbage
on earth in 2023
not watch network television commercials
and so we have this incredible
opportunity to start building brand and
social through brand work that is not
measurable the same way that these
brands want and they have to start
having a better conversation
of understanding it's like a fighter in
mma you got a left hand you got a right
hand so many people trying to fight with
just one hand and which hand is it and
boy oh boy is it a wild matrix out there
right now but i think gary i know you're
super passionate about it tonight i
understand
you know everything that you're saying
but that's internally at these
organizations marketing and sales it's
moving closer together it's actually
being centralized
that's great the problem that's not the
i mean that's phenomenal because that's
business
go ahead right
but what but the kpi
is becoming more and more sales and less
and less brand every day
by the way which is actually fantastic
when nobody understands yet is
sales is just bad marketing
mean it
need it there you go meaning yeah
it's very lovely i sold
almost a million dollars worth of
re-friends hoodies not because i [ __ ]
cookied all these people in the chat but
because i built
brand is sales these [ __ ]
did not cookie my phone
they did this and i think to your point
and by the way i love it because i love
doing digital sales
to give me air cover to do proper
digital branding
i think the the
challenge with these brands is that
still which is just crazy to me and i've
been doing this part of the industry for
15 years they still rely on these media
mix models
to
especially spit out how much revenue do
we drive and it just comes down to that
conversation [ __ ] reports
you know what it reminds me of
this
you know what this is
what your first your first sale
oh your high school your secondary
school report card
my high school report card you know what
i call this a [ __ ] report you want
to hear one
you want to hear one rach let's hear it
sophomore sophomore year speech
it's right there speed yeah you see it
speech yeah you see it cp
d oh you got it
wow
i got a d in speech it's amazing what
else do you [ __ ] want to know about
[ __ ] reports
yeah no i i totally understand
so anyway i i think your points taken
and i think
for a lot of people because these are
all so short and i got to move the show
along
rachel has consistently i invested
rachel how fast did i invest in your
company in our first meeting honestly
three minutes three minutes
say it for everybody one more time three
minutes
how many years later are we here
seven and a half
seven and a half years ago
in three minutes of conversation i wrote
a check into rachel's company why
because i had an intuition that has been
proven very very true in the last seven
and a half years which is this woman's
ability to adjust to the reality of the
marketplace is
real and i have that so i can sense it
and very few people have it
if you're interested in what rachel's
talking about here which is absolutely 1
000 true
on the concept of big brands moving a
lot of their media dollars into the
walmarts and the targets and the other
retailers media offerings
there's a ton of innovation and business
and opportunity in there and i highly
recommend you get very close to things
that she's writing about podcasting
about you can learn something you'll
probably ask her for a job on your
second piece of content consumed and if
nothing else it's just good for you to
know her
thank you for time
cheers
thanks rachel
thanks gary for putting in the time all
kinds of chat going on how does he do it
all how is he how is he working on vcon
and he's jumping on this show
i'll tell you how
because i didn't respect them because i
said [ __ ] this system that's why because
this system told me to do one thing this
system told me to do one thing and i
told the system they were wrong
they are wrong
you're so much more than a c plus you're
an a plus plus plus thank you gary i
would have taken a i would have taken a
c plus by the way on the record i would
take it
just to zoom in here let's remind that's
right what do you see the gpa
look at the class rank tell me what i
can't see it gary honestly
my class rank
was 243
out of 254.
i was i was the 11th
12th worst student in the entire class i
had a 1.67 gpa
oh my god yeah and now and now look what
you are and that's why you're
revolutionizing everything and the best
part is you know what's you know the
look where i am now has nothing to do
with the business success
what what i really learned in high
school was that i was not willing to go
to the final level of popularity by
compromising my kindness
in high school to be the super most
popular
you have to be willing to pick on people
that was just a culture and i wasn't
willing to compromise that and so what i
really learned at high school and look
at who i am now is
i'm a nice person
and that was the and to be able to go
through high school and deal with peer
pressure at that level
and not compromise your soul and your
kindness
is
the thing i'm most proud about not the
fact that i became
a very good businessman with bad grades
yeah and we're so lucky to be at vayner
where you've been able to give that gift
um in such a major way i mean we just we
the fact that we can scale an
organization because people love each
other and they trust each other
um first and they do great work and they
do it fast because of it is it's real i
didn't believe there was a company out
like that anywhere but uh
you found it but i found it i love it
we'll talk to you thank you
all right now we're going to bring up
our ceo of gallery media group ryan
harwood
how's it going ryan it's all good
too long i'm excited ready to go i'm so
excited too we're going to bring up rob
master of unilever he's the vp of media
and marketing
and he leads all so much media in
innovation strategy integrated
communications for all of unilever's
brands
and check this out under rob's
leadership unilever has been recognized
as digital marketer of the year by
advertising age a media client of the
year by media post and one of the fast
fast companies most innovative marketers
wow
welcome rob
how you doing great to be here great to
be here
how's it going ron take a moment just
like just to like reflect on gary vee
and i i've known gary for actually well
over a decade and just to see the growth
i mean just
so much fun so much energy so so thank
you for having me
uh on the show today this is great
absolutely did you did you do well in
school rob
i mean i was like a middle middling
student i wasn't like gary v level but i
certainly wasn't like ivy league level i
was i'm a big ten guy so you know
i you know it's funny i as gary's
partner i debate him on this all the
time that you know he says grades don't
matter i say grades matter that you
should try if you can try we get into it
all the time but i respect his opinion
and i i totally get it but i am pumped
to have you on the show rob for
everybody rob is a long time friend and
colleague he runs media and marketing at
unilever and he is a legend in the
industry so i'm pumped to have him on
um you know 2022 is fully arrived
let's talk about where you're seeing the
other day you mentioned to me streaming
wars was something that was going
through your head we know that netflix
was the early dominant player but they
have a lot of competition now
tell me what's going on in your head
there yeah so i think 20 yeah 2022 will
be the year of the streaming war
i think it's actually unbelievably
exciting and competitive landscape to
watch from the sidelines um although we
certainly have a major role to play in
it um but i think it's interesting we
reflect on netflix as you said they were
the long time player they really had no
direct competition for almost like a
decade of course there was hulu but hulu
was kind of an aggregator
i think in 2022 netflix faces i think
two kind of competitors
the first is kind of the traditional
media companies the paramounts the
disney's the warren discovery merger
and these guys are all in
i mean they're retaking back their
content whether it be the office or
friends so they're taking it from
netflix
they're creating enormous amount of
original content development that
they're putting on their streaming
platforms they're getting they're all in
on marketing they're thinking about the
consumer in a different way than they've
ever thought before and i think if you
look at the user interfaces they're
really good
um i think that as you know they're
really solid they're good they're good
experiences and for them i think it's
interesting the disney's the warner's
this is a burning platform for these
guys this is like they can't see
anything more than netflix i think they
kind of let netflix go on for too long
but now they're all in
and so while it's not a zero-sum game
because people will have multiple
subscriptions i think it's an area they
have to win and win big
the other competitor so you have the
traditional kind of media companies the
other competitor is a totally different
ballgame you're probably the two most
powerful companies in the world and
apple and amazon and so this isn't
necessarily their core business and i'm
not sure if it's a hobby or a loss
leader or what they're thinking about
but it's certainly part of their overall
business strategy and i think you know
that's a different set of competitors
than the disney's and the warner's
and so i look at netflix and i think
um you know they're competing for
consumers now in a different way but
more importantly i think for their
business model they're competing for
content with disney and with amazon and
apple and i think that's a totally
different like cost model for them and
they have a single revenue stream and i
just i think you're beginning to see
signs of that that that business model
crack because you know you know apples
look in the hardware business amazon
sells web services and soap yeah and you
know they have all these other revenue
streams as is you know disney so i think
i think the netflix model will
definitely have to change is my
perspective how does how does this the
streaming wars affect a company like
unilever like given that you can't
advertise on a lot of these platforms
but like how does it consume your your
headspace in the integrated marketing
and media world where do you fit into
this world yes i think you know we're
obviously watching very closely um the
transition from like traditional
television which is still like you know
provides some big numbers but to
streaming and and certainly we're very
supportive of these ad supported models
like
like hbo max and paramount plus and hulu
these guys are an important part of our
mix because it's i think it's a great
consumer experience i mean in the end i
think
we're gonna have so many subscriptions
we're gonna rue the day that we forgot
about the cable bundle to some degree
but that's a whole different
conversation but i i do think that for
us we're really looking at innovative
and creative ways to leverage these
streaming platforms which are almost
like a reset
like innovative ads targeting
audience like there's just so much you
could do in streaming that you can't do
in linear and [ __ ] you can't
necessarily do in social because like
we're talking about terrific amazing
content not that tick tock doesn't great
content or facebook but i think this
high quality content and associating
yourself with it is a huge opportunity
for brands like cars and by doing it
innovatively yeah it also allows you to
put out a high volume of various
variety of ads so it's not one vanilla
piece of content that goes on linear and
you're hoping and praying that resonates
now you can do a lot of different
variations so i'm excited for that as
well totally totally
talk to me about um the conversions of
media and commerce you know this reminds
me of how
athletes wanted to be musicians and
musicians wanted to be athletes and now
they all want to be entrepreneurs it
seems like media companies want to be
commerce companies commerce companies
want to be media companies what are you
seeing here so of course i i love that
kind of metaphor analogy i think it's
it's great that we came right after
rachel and gary because i think i think
what we're seeing is this convergence of
media and and commerce take place at
such a force and really i think was
accelerated uh accelerated by the covid
experience and listen i get it if i'm a
retailer you're looking at the media
business it's a great business it's a
high margin business and by the way
retailers have great data and i think
you just start looking at some of the
market caps and the story it tells a
clear story like look at like snapchat
where they have a couple thousand
employees
and their market cap is significantly
bigger than someone like kroger who's
the largest grocer in america has
probably a half a million employees and
you know
you know that's a totally different kind
of margin business they got real estate
they got logistics they have weather
they got karen's going wild in stores i
mean it's a totally different experience
versus snap so i think yes i'm i'm in
the retail space i look at with envy for
the media business and and to your point
i think the media guys are see upside in
being in the commerce business and so i
think for good reason um you know one is
it's a way for them to enhance their
consumer experience by either keeping
people uh frictionless in buying
products experiencing products on their
site spending more time by the way more
time on their site means more ads by the
way they can sell ads that are like
specializing in kind of like shoppable
so they can charge a higher price for
that
um and the other part is i think
um it's another revenue stream so tick
tock's getting into this facebook
they're getting into kind of like
commission based sales so i think this
convergence is coming from both ends
again the brands are going to be
important for us to play an important
role you know we talk about the retail
media players you know we want to make
sure that they're operating like me to
media players with similar standards and
ways of working than the rest of the
media industry everyone loves uniqueness
that's cool but we got to make sure that
like can our ads be seen by humans in
safe environments can they be
third-party measure these are the things
that retailers really going to have to
embrace but overall we're really excited
about this convergence
awesome
um this is a short 10 minutes we get so
i want to jump into the third area that
i'd love your hot take on is is name
image likeness with college athletes has
unilever dabbled in this sector at all
yeah so just to give some context so the
name image lightness is a space that
essentially the context here is that on
july 1st college athletes were able to
profit from their name image and
likeness and went live july 1st and
actually we were the first major
advertiser to jump in we've been a long
time ncaa sponsor so we've been watching
this space closely very supportive of
athletes getting involved and you know
we looked as an opportunity to like have
a thoughtful precedent it's just not all
about like the top quarterback in the
country the number one draft pick in
basketball we really were looking for a
diverse set of athletes across the
spectrum of sports to bring this to life
um and about 10 months in it's actually
as much as we tried setting a precedent
to be productive and not just hawking
products and thinking purpose and
diversity we're seeing kind of like a
bit of the wild west a lot of
predominantly football whether it be
texas a m or university of texas doing a
lot of kind of like
interesting things and air quotes i
think with how they're how they're
getting involved with the college
athletes which i think is a bit of a
concern
um
and uh it's something that we're
certainly watching closely but our
program we launched with degree our
brand degree and with this whole purpose
around breaking limits so we brought in
19 student athletes
um wonderful kids from across sports
race socioeconomic backgrounds
uh sexual orientation geography and like
we brought them in
ten women nine men and we had them tell
their stories about how they broke
limits very much tied with our purpose
and so it was like an amazing experience
amazing uh kids
and what's great about we didn't just
start stop there we actually did
mentorships with them because the
reality is most college athletes are not
going to make their living through the
sport so we work with a number of them
now as as mentors so i have a great kid
named chase griffith he's a he's a um
ucla quarterback
um not the starter
i'm surprised you didn't do all
wisconsin players so we actually have we
have we have a bunch of wisconsin
players we have a terrific kid who's a
computer like engineering major we
partnered him with our head of supply
chain one of our hudson supply chain who
also played sports at west point so it's
an amazing experience to like connect
with these kids and i think it's a
provides a lot of energizing and passion
for us as well we gotta we got a wrap
we're at time i'm gonna go real quick on
the speed round questions that's my
patent here salty or sweet rob
it's a tough one between cashews and
gummy bears i'm gonna go with gummy
bears
80s or 90s music
i mean you got thriller and molly crew
i'm going all 80s 80s sly stallone or
arnold schwarzenegger
i got balboa and rambo no question
last one friends are seinfeld
i think ultimately in 15 years i'll be
living in del cabo double vista so there
you go
i love it thank you so much for coming
on the show rob we appreciate it all
right thanks for having me take care
thanks ryan you're we got to get you
your own show just with that one with
those rapid-fire questions they're the
best
hello thank you so much for joining us
ryan
we'll see you soon all right next up
we've got our executive director of the
sasha group mickey cloud
hey andre how are you oh i love it love
it a little bit of this got the screen
in porch life
nice nice nice so we're super fired up
to have a conversation between you and
kevin miller who's the cmo of the of
fresh market
kevin has been an industry disruptor for
a long time he's got a 30-year career
he's worked with a ton of fortune 100
companies i'm going to rattle a few of
them off
natural grocers pizza hut subway
coca-cola mcdonald's and more
and i think most importantly we really
want to thank kevin uh and his family
for his service in the military welcome
kevin
all righty happy to be here guys hey
kevin how are you all right how you
doing mickey doing great super excited
to have you on marketing for the now you
know we know just hearing those brands
that under rattled off your entire
career has kind of been at the
intersection of food and retail um and
so as you you know are a quarter into
2022 what's kind of the number one hot
take most macro priority for you know uh
retail businesses and how does that
apply to kind of your grocery world and
with the fresh market yeah yeah so um a
little bit about the fresh market first
you know we're not as famous as uh
unilever but we're doing okay
so we're uh we're a two billion dollar
brand
we have 149 stores in uh in 20 states
and the fresh market was was was uh
founded on the idea of providing you
know the best food fresh food from
around the world curated uh to our
customers and given the best service and
so for us
you know our product quality is very
important but the actual experience of
shopping at the fresh market is equally
important to our customers in fact we
have a much higher elevated expectation
our customers expect us
to provide the same level of service as
a nordstrom's or
you know a rich carlton it's not just a
little bit better they expect but they
expect a whole lot better experience and
a whole lot better level of impeccable
service so that is really an important
aspect as you look at all the
you know the movement toward technology
and you know the
the impact of covid and inflation
and there are a number of things that
are going on out there
that uh you know keep me up at night
i'll just name a few jimmy fallon
yeah are you ready
all right
digital
the
the physical world colliding
with the digital world hey i'll get this
right we'll turn into marketing
dinosaurs
next
well
you know what is happening in 2022 well
3.0 are you kidding me
i'm still working on web 1.0
3.0
next
i think we heard it on a couple other
ones live
commerce
i didn't know commerce was dead
[Laughter]
i love this jimmy the jimmy fallon bit
here okay here we go all right what's
the last one well i gotta go more okay
metabolism metaverse that's important
because zuckerberg said it is
all right non-fungible tokens nfts yeah
that's hard to read yeah because it's
hard to understand too
all right well all this is kind of
adding up for us and for me
is
was predicted by james and elizabeth 30
years ago
and that the more technology
we introduce into society the more
people will aggregate will want to be
with each other other people movies rock
concerts and shopping
that's high tech high touch
and we all seen it we all talked about
it
it's like people are tired of being on
zoom
without wearing masks
and whenever anyone attends the
conference they're very happy just to
see other people
and so how do you
make that experience
of high-tech high-touch
you know come to life against all the
various platforms against all the
different customers all the different
shopping experiences
that is really our challenge for 2022
and beyond i love that because i mean
as a as a shopper at the fresh market
and someone who grew up in the state of
north carolina where you guys are based
it that shopping experience it is a vibe
right like
only classical music playing you've got
the fresh flowers the fresh fruit you
you you get that zen like experience
when you are physically in in that in in
the store in the location
how do you translate that experience for
a shopper that wants to order on
instacart that wants to do curbside
delivery that wants to do the ecom side
of the business and and how do you make
sure that you're still hitting that
sensorial experience for someone that's
shopping digitally
yeah so you got all those platforms and
technologies we just talked about
but the where you had to start is with
the
you know with the brand and really
understanding your brand your brand dna
and your brand promise better than
anyone else
um
and from that you need to develop a
brand vision
so our brand vision is to become one of
america's most loved brands
and that's because we're leaning into
jimmy kimmel
human spirit and love
spirit and love it's just that simple
and so about anchoring our business
into
pleasing our customers
with impeccable guest service with the
highest quality products they can find
anywhere
and providing that with a sense of love
and passion
then we have to then
translate that feeling
that tone
to the right customer at the right place
at the right time and we've all said
that before but here's the additional
kicker in the right way
in the way that they want to receive our
message in our storytelling on the
devices they want to receive it in a
time when they want to consume that
content and so you have to invest
with working with very smart people and
organizations and partners like the
sasha group to help you know translate
that brand experience that brand promise
that level expectations that the
customer expects of you
into these platforms where they are
where they're living
that's not a uh something you can solve
overnight yeah it's something that you
have to work on and experiment with
constantly it goes back to what gary was
talking about with rachel earlier about
how its brand is ultimately going to be
the thing that unlocks the sales and so
i love that for you know as you guys
have started to think about that with
the curbside pickup experience and kind
of the concierge level of
that's not just a okay i'm going to drop
it off and you've got to come in and
walk it can you talk a little bit about
how that's how you guys are thinking
about that yep so that goes back to
again you know walking the talk
really understanding who your brand is
and what your customers expect of you
so we um
we knew that going into
the
holiday selling season of 2022
uh 2020 excuse me
that that was the first year for colvin
uh the first holiday impacted by copen
we knew the covert wasn't over in fact
it was surging in that you know curbside
would be a very important
aspect of our customer experience for
the holiday season 2020 for the first
time ever
and so we engaged a uh a terrific
consulting firm that specializes in the
digital world
really smart in terms of technologies
understanding and road mapping the
consumer journey from the time they you
know pick up their phone and begin to
order on instacart
to the experience of them placing the
order driving to the store
arriving at the store communicating
but we didn't stop there with the
technical side we re-engineered the
actual physical experience of our
internal
employees who would shop
for the customers we empower them with
more more phones and more tools to
communicate directly with our customers
and then we
backed up
the experience that we called the
friendliest curbside experience in
america
we backed that up by guaranteeing the
accuracy of the
products we empowered our shoppers to
provide special surprise and delight
gifts to the curbside like a bottle of
water on on a hot day
and change the experience during the
holiday season again we customers expect
us to treat them really nicely all the
time and especially during the holidays
of course where they trust us with their
shopping and their family
their family meals and so we had santa
claus so we
had
oily costume santa clauses a lot of that
from the boots
to the candy canes who
were who came out and provided curbside
service during the holidays i love that
i love that so that was really terrific
sales went way up customer satisfaction
went way up and then we were
recognized by one side grocer the
friendliest curbside experience in
america was recognized as one of the top
10 digital innovations in all of food
service retail food service love it love
it well
the last thing as we wrap up this 10
minutes goes by so quick last thing i
want to ask is you know one of our
priorities is making is spreading that
brand love into the world of tick tock
for 2022 for for the fresh market what's
your personal favorite tick tock trend
or hashtag what have you started to play
around on the platform and what pops out
to you
oh
i'm just you know i watch a lot of the
nba stuff awesome yeah they really have
brought the nba experience to the palm
of your hand yeah so you get to
see who's
talking about gossiping about whatever
but you also they really post a lot of
the really key stats yeah uh the the key
players the historical players so it's
very educational informative and it's
gossipy i've gotten to the gospel point
i've gotten into some deep deep rabbit
holes of nba tick tock where it's like
former players like kevin garnett
telling stories about tim duncan talking
you know trash to him and just how like
oh so many good stories that find my way
because
humanity the human spirit and love
that's the way to go i love it i love it
well thank you so much
the marketers are
we're not
advocating our position gary
it's all about our brand marketers brand
marketers that's right you better
believe it that's 100 right all right
thanks kevin thanks guys
love that thank you mickey go enjoy go
enjoy that porch will do that was
amazing
all right last but not least let's bring
nick m up on the stage our executive
vice president oh what is going on
i love the fact that we're we're going
to have we're getting all the greeks to
unite here in this last conversation
we're closing it out i mean that's right
now we got a party meadows and are going
to break some plates in a minute that's
right well let us let me just uh set the
stage a little bit for uh for manos
who's going to be joining us manos
spanos he's the president of el nutra
consumer health and nutrition and i'm
really excited i'm going to be taking
lots of notes during this one
he's scaling the company super fast
because he's got breakthrough science
that's aimed at optimizing health span
curing disease and extending life
naturally what what better than that
i guess we're gonna find out all right
take it away nick and welcome
hello hello what is up brother have you
been
all good my brother all good great
tonight as you said there we go oh i
agree
nice way to close the day
so i've been fasting all day in
preparation for this i feel really good
but why don't you ground our audience
real quick on a little background on you
the company for those who might not be
that familiar with the brand
absolutely um and i'm sure a lot are not
so el nutra elementary is a little
company that is going to become huge in
the next few years so be on the lookout
it's the company that stole my heart
after 20 years of cpg career in jnj
pepsico and dan on so i progressively
moved towards more healthy options um
and i think i landed in the healthiest
one of all which is which is almost
um in el nutra we aim to add life to
life we aim to extend to help extend uh
human longevity in natural ways how the
hell are we going to do that well by
being in one of the areas that one of
the things that we do every day
nutrition what's the thing that you do
every day man you eat um and you eat
actually multiple times a day so we're
going to be we're in the world of
nutrition and more specifically
nutritional technology
and the two first approaches that we
have on how to do that
is two areas one the area of how can you
leverage the benefits of fasting uh but
fasting with food so get all the good
things and we're gonna talk about that
stuff um around fasting but do it in a
way that you don't starve yourself you
don't go in the water fast and you don't
you know you don't do damage to your
organs so fasting with food and then the
second area that we are that we are
working really hard on is the area of
understanding exactly what is behind the
longevity zones across the world the
areas where people get to live over 100
years old what exactly do they do in
their nutrition how do they do it what
is in it what's the what's the
technology of takes off of that and you
know small spoiler alert fasting is a
key part of that too so there you go um
so those are the first two areas that
that we're working on there's more that
are coming um
at the at the other end with more
technology but this is the first two
things that we're tackling um and yeah
we do have uh programs and products that
actually work um and that's what
differentiate us the last thing that i
would say about el nutra is it's the
first time in my life that i've been in
a cpg company that has
already done 17 clinical studies
completed be reviewed double blind i've
in humans in animals published in the
biggest science magazines in the world
um
to back up every single claim that we
have so we've done 17 and we've got 12
that are that are on their way so if you
find me another cpg company that has
anywhere near that number of clinical
studies behind the products
i'll i'll join them all right so let's
go with some hot takes here um
fasting as a lifestyle you know
is this a niche is this a fed is this
the next whole 30 like for the cynics
out there what's the hot take
well if it's a fad is the longest the
longest running fight in the universe
because we've been doing it since
humanity ever started right first humans
started fasting and you know for god's
sakes take any religion in the world you
name it whichever religion in the world
what are the two things that they have
in common you pray and you fast
so humans always knew fasting is good
for you what has changed the last few
years is that we now know exactly what
is the good that this does which is the
cellular rejuvenation which is the fact
that your cells are basically cleaning
up house and creating new versions of
themselves
and we now understand how what is the
mechanism behind that which is autophagy
and then we now also understand how the
hell can we induce that
in a quick way in the body
even though you're eating you can still
get in a state of autophagy which will
create all the benefits of fasting with
food so that's what changed so for me i
don't think it's a fad i think more and
more people are realizing that what
they've been doing anyways whether they
were part of a religion or not by the
way every every night you sleep you fast
you have to understand every night just
like you just fast for 12 hours
the whole thing is how can you get this
12 hours to 16 and then how to can you
go to prolonged fasting and do it over
four to five days that's the only thing
but you do it every single day so it's
it's not a fad it's something that
people are realizing that it actually is
helpful and i think more and more people
are are jumping on the bandwagon
we're closing we're closing towards uh
half a million people already um going
through our programs so
and what have you seen so far is the
biggest barrier for the consumer is it
just general knowledge awareness
well the biggest barrier is the reason
why
i think vayner
which is how the hell do you explain to
people that you can eat
and get the benefits of fasting at the
same time it's just it's just that
awareness it's it's really it's not an
easy thing it's not something that i can
that we can do over 30 seconds of a tv
spot right it's just not easy so it
requires a lot of education it requires
the health professionals to educate
people on and we have a pretty strong
health professional program it takes
advocates from all different kinds of um
of
of genders to to help us spread the
message educate in in non-traditional
ways so this is not gonna happen over i
put a tvc up there and i tell you that
this works this is gonna happen by
working with a lot of people to spread
the word out there okay cool jumping
around a little bit i know we don't have
that much time but um
concept of preventative health and
longevity of life i mean that's a hot
take in of itself ground our audience
ground our audience innovative health
what do we need to know
in my in my opinion biggest miss
opportunity in the whole corporate
situation um because we focused
everything around kovit in prevention
through drugs through either the
vaccines or through drugs that treat the
coffee which is great thank god we have
those that's that's wonderful nothing is
a
triple vaccinated quadruple vaccinated
already so we're fine but um but we
missed a huge opportunity to talk about
preventative uh preventative health to
talk about how can we prevent disease
how can we strengthen our immunity
systems how can we reduce obesity and
there's lots that that are played there
we lost an opportunity in the world of
of working out and fitness and that
stuff and we definitely lost an
opportunity in the world of nutrition
and we're trying to spot like that
because you can do things through
nutrition
for example what we are what we are
saying is you know going through the the
the fasting for the nutrition programs
so you can do stuff for your body and
you can do stuff that strengthens your
immunity systems that reduce obesity
that curb the effects the effect that
obesity and other diseases have on you i
mean it's you can and should be doing
that so let's please not let this
opportunity go by completely let's talk
about that let's talk about nutrition
let's talk about that role in
preventative health it's very important
and hot take on that is as the world
opens up goes back to a more normal
state of people leaving the house where
maybe it was even challenged for anybody
to realize that while they were we were
all sitting at home you know um how does
it shift as people go on the go again
you know you've been in food for a long
time the formats the change from direct
to consumer to now buying in stores
because they're on the road um any hot
takes there
yeah well i think
we're gonna see
some of the things that happened
pre-pandemic
so the growth of the on-the-go which was
a pretty clean one that's gonna that's
gonna start going up again for sure i
mean you have to um you're gonna see
again you're gonna see a lot and one of
the previous uh speakers from fresh
market actually talking about this that
the more technology you bring in
actually the more people want to go in
the in the shops and and shop
and interact so i think you're going to
see a little bit of that um but what
you're also going to see i think is more
potent solutions through nutrition
things that actually work have a
functional benefit so you're going to
see functional food
growing i think faster than it had been
growing before why because we realize
now we are living a short life and you
know this thing can happen anytime so
the more you can do through your food to
strengthen your body um i think the
better it is so you're going to see a
lot of functional food growing
at the same time as on the go
and
as that takes off
does it have to taste like crap or can
it be really cold
i don't care what marketing research
says if it doesn't taste good it's not
gonna work sorry i i know people say i'm
willing to sacrifice taste if it works
it just can't now that doesn't mean it
has to be done with sugar by the way
there is there's plenty other ways of
doing it but man it can't taste bad like
and
we've realized that i mean for quite a
while we had one version of our product
right so it was the one version of
problem that had this specific four or
five soups there we're changing all that
now we're adding a lot more variety all
clinically researched and backed but
people need variety people need taste um
if it doesn't taste right you're not
gonna have it i don't know what it is a
hot take against that one
i go to the store now and the amount of
bars i see everywhere oh [ __ ] like we've
reached peak bar yeah
like what's going to happen in the bar
uh aisle or it's gonna it's gonna
explode um the same thing that happened
to the yogurt the isle which was my
previous world uh
there's just a point of saturation that
that you know you know everybody smells
money on on a category everybody rushes
behind it and and then you've got this
explosion and the retailers are happy to
get you know another half a point here
another half a point there so they'll
bring in um all this new variety i think
what ultimately happens and you can see
that very quickly happening also in the
yogurt aisle you'll see it in the bar
aisle what will happen is it will shrink
and only the differentiated players will
make the top the top five six brands
have no problem they're gonna be there
because they have a reason for being
there but what you're gonna see is very
quickly consolidation of all the small
stuff and who's going to remain is
people that are offering something
differentiated something and no one else
has fastbar which is the one that we're
having right now and we're expanding at
retail and we're seeing an incredible
reception from retail it is the only bar
that you can have if you're intermittent
fasting in the morning without breaking
your fast again food but doesn't break
your fast that's a hot take itself
like continue
you don't break your fat so
things like this things that really have
a difference will stay now do we need 20
protein bars that have 15 16 7
8 grams of protein no we need probably
two or three of them so yeah
how take
where is the protein threshold
oh shoot uh well i'll i'll i'll revert
back to my previous world well any
anything over 20 20 25 grams that that's
what i mean for and not like for
somebody that is working out in the
fitness world and wants a serious amount
of protein i think 20 grams per serving
i think is more than enough all right
good i'm learning so much i hope the
audiences too
um i think we got to wrap in a minute
but let's go hot takes in the world
media you know the past couple years
the rise of tick-tock
instagram reels trying to be tick-tock
youtube shorts how are you thinking
about like the ever-changing world of
media the metaverse all of that and
building brands
all the while
one clear winner one potential winner in
the future and then one that i think you
guys talked about uh two two shots back
but that is also very important clear
winner on tick tock tick tock is
obviously winning a lot of a lot of
presents with from brands and a lot of
interaction and engagement so that's a
clear clear winner not just that he took
the channel but he took the format of
cult yeah now we're using tiktok format
to go on facebook right so um i think
that's a clear winner even though
they're hard to work with but we're
going to work on that um so that's not a
clear winner i think a potential winner
in the future is the metaverse i mean
what's happening now is in the
borderline insane right with between
nfcs and buying yes real estate on like
it's it's just insane but it's coming
there will be a market there now how big
that market is i don't know yet but i
think there will be a market there so i
think definitely we need to watch out
the metaphors um and then the one that
you guys talked about already is retail
media um it makes all the sense of the
world
they've got they've got the audience
they've got the better targeting um
i actually see them as a more effective
tool for brands that are at retail
versus the traditional advertisement on
facebook um or or instagram i've because
because of the targeting you just you
can do so much more with retail media um
so
that's right
last one in 30 seconds hot take on the
future of work you know because it's
also the future of how we eat where we
eat um how are you thinking about that
whether personally at the company or in
the macro of civilization all right i
think i think i'm in the minority here
saying that there's nothing that
replaces human interaction man i can't
be doing this remote all the time i go
go make a deal with somebody in the
middle east without having dinner and a
shisha
good luck with that man yeah that's not
happening
go make a deal over zoom with anyone in
the middle east
it's not i mean it just can't happen and
it's the same thing in america and other
places people need human interaction
people need to see each other do we need
to be five days in the office no um
probably three two three two
sure there's gonna be more flexibility
for sure and that's great but don't tell
me that zoom calls are gonna replace the
offices forever because it's not gonna
happen it's just not gonna happen people
need to sit in a corridor and talk and
chat and have a coffee and have fun and
go down have a lunch and solve business
problems on the go we cannot do that
with
i
zoom
with you i agree with you and i can't
wait to see you um and a massive thank
you for running the show this has been
awesome thanks nick
can't wait to live everybody yep 100
plus you and i bye
thanks nick that was awesome oh my gosh
i learned so much we gotta go google a
lot of stuff right now i know exactly i
know make sense of it all right this is
life-changing stuff
you're on fire
all right
in the greeks all right thanks nick
we'll see you soon in the office
all right thanks everybody for joining
this this uh extended marketing for the
now and i hope you're gonna join us for
our second anniversary edition in may
we'll be live may 26th at 12 noon
eastern time so please come and join us
we're gonna be talking we're gonna have
a big celebration we're gonna be talking
a lot about community and what it takes
to build it so keep the conversation
going uh hashtag marketing for the now
and i will see you very very soon take
care